GOOD NIGHT.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
LAST NIGHT ON THIS SHOW WE
TOLD YOU WHAT MAY BE THE
SINGLE MOST EXTREME AND
DISRUPTIVE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION EVER TO GAIN
WIDESPREAD SUPPORT IN THE
CONGRESS IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
IT’S CALLED THE NEW WAY
FORWARD ACT.
IT’S BEFORE CONGRESS RIGHT
NOW AND HAS BEEN FOR ALMOST
TWO MONTHS.
AND, YET, SO FAR IT HAS BEEN
ESSENTIALLY IGNORED BY THE
COUNTRY’S MAJOR MEDIA
OUTLETS WHICH ARE EITHER TOO
EMBARRASSED OR TOO IGNORANT
TO COVER IT.
THAT’S A DISSERVICE TO YOU
IT’S REALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
DESCRIBE JUST HOW RADICAL
THIS BILL IS.
IF PASSED IT WOULD REMAKE
OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM FOR
THE EXPRESSED PURPOSE OF
HELPING FOREIGN-BORN
CRIMINALS LIVE HERE.
THE BILL WOULD ALLOW PEOPLE
WHO HAVE COMMITTED SERIOUS
FELONIES IN OTHER COUNTRIES
TO MOVE TO THE UNITED STATES
LEGALLY.
IT WOULD MAKE IT NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION OFFICIALS TO
DETAIN IMMIGRANTS NO MATTER
HOW POTENTIALLY CHRIS THIS DANGE
THEY ARE.
AND PERHAPS MOST
INFURIATINGLY AND REMARKABLY
IT WOULD REQUIRE TAXPAYERS
TO IMPORT DEPORTED CRIMINALS
BACK INTO THE UNITED STATES.
HURT OURYOU BREAK OUR
LAWS AND HURT OUR PEOPLE WE
WILL PAY FOR YOU TO COME
BACK.
IT’S UTTER AND TOTAL
INSANITY.
YET, VERY POPULAR IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SO FAR THIS BILL HAS 44
DEMOCRATIC CO-SPONSORS.
ON THE SCREEN IS A LIST OF
SOME OF THEIR NAMES.
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE YOU
HAVE HEARD OF BEFORE.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ,
ILHAN OMAR, RASHIDA TLAIB.
THEY ARE CELEBRITIES.
SOME ARE OBSCURE EARL
BLUMENAUER HAS REPRESENTED
OREGON FOR DECADES.
BEFORE THIS HE MAY BE BEST
KNOWN FOR RUNNING THE
CONGRESSIONAL BICYCLE
CAUCUS.
AND, YET, ALL OF A SUDDEN
OUT OF NOWHERE BLUMENAUER
HAS DECIDED TO WRECK THE
COUNTRY.
WE WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO
BLUMENAUER ON THIS SHOW.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HEAR WHY HE
SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
WE WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO ANY
OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CO-SPONSORED IT.
WE REACHED OUT TO MANY OF
THEM TODAY TO COME ON AND
DEFEND THEIR VIEWS.
NOT ONE OF THEM AGREED TO
COME?
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY ARE COWARDS.
YET, WE THINK YOU OUGHT TO
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
HERE IS THE BILL’S PRIMARY
SPONSOR JESUS GARCIA OF
ILLINOIS AFTER INTRODUCING
THE BILL.
GARCIA SAID THIS.
>> THIS IS NOT A RADICAL
PROJECT.
WE ARE SIMPLY ASKING FOR A
FAIR SHOT AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR IMMIGRANTS
TO STAY IN THE COUNTRY THEY
CALL HOME.
A NEW WAY FORWARD DOES JUST
THAT.
IT WOULD END MANDATORY
IMMIGRATION DETENTION, END
THE AUTOMATIC PIPELINE TO
DEPORTATION THROUGH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT WOULD END DEPORTATION
POOR PEOPLE WHODEPOOR FORPEOPLE
WITH THE CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
SYSTEM.
WOULD END PRACTICES WITH THE
POLICE ENGAGING IN
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT AND
THE INCREASE EVERPOLICING OF
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
IT WOULD DO CRIMINALIZE
IMMIGRATION.
>> Tucker: THIS IS NOT A
RADICAL PROJECT.
OF COURSE, THE OPPOSITE IS
TRUE.
THE BILL IS COMPLETELY
RADICAL.
IT WOULD TRANSFORM AMERICA
INTO A PLACE YOU DON’T
RECOGNIZE.
MANY OF THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL COME FROM THE FRINGES
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS
YOU WOULD EXPECT.
BUT, NOT ALL OF THEM DO.
CONSIDER CONGRESSMAN ANDY
LEVIN, LEVIN REPRESENTS THE
SUBURBS NORTH OF DETROIT.
LEVIN’S DISTRICT LEANS BLUE
BUT IT’S STILL ESSENTIALLY
BIPARTISAN.
VOTERS WENT FOR HILLARY
CLINTON FOR EXAMPLE BY JUST
8 POINTS.
SO THERE IS NO CHANCE A
MAJORITY OF ANDY LEVIN’S
VOTERS WANT TO SEND PLANE
TICKETS TO ARMED ROBBERS IN
GUATEMALA SO THEY CAN MOVE
NEXT DOOR.
IN EFFECT, NOBODY WANTS
THAT, NO MATTER WHAT THEY
CLAIM ON TWITTER.
YET, LEVIN IS TRYING TO DO
THAT RIGHT NOW.
THAT’S WHAT’S SCARY ABOUT
THIS BILL, IT’S HAPPENING IN
THE DARK.
NO ONE IS TALKING ABOUT IT.
THOSE WHO ARE DISMISS IT AS
UNLIKELY.
IT WILL NEVER HAPPEN.
THAT’S A MISTAKE.
THINGS CHANGE FAST IN MODERN
AMERICA.
ON ISSUE AFTER ISSUE, FROM
END THE SECOND AMENDMENT TO
BANNING BIOLOGICAL GENDER TO
THE OPEN AND AGGRESSIVE
RACISM OF IDENTITY POLITICS.
YESTERDAY’S EXTREMISM HAS
BECOME TODAY’S DEMOCRATIC
PARTY PLATFORM.
THAT’S HOW IT WORKS NOW.
FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN BERNIE
SANDERS MOUNTED HIS FIRST
CAMPAIGN FOR PRESIDENT,
VOX.COM PRESSED HIM ON WHY
HE DIDN’T BACK OPEN BORDERS
FOR THE WORLD.
SANDERS RESPONDED THIS WAY,
QUOTE:  NO, THAT’S A KOCH
BROTHERS PROPOSAL WHICH SAYS
ESSENTIALLY THERE IS NO
UNITED STATES.
IT WOULD MAKE EVERYBODY IN
AMERICA POORER, END QUOTE.
OF COURSE, SANDERS WAS
ENTIRELY RIGHT AND FOR THAT
CRIME HE WAS SAVAGED BY VOX
AND ALL THE OTHER ANGRY
CHILDREN IN WOKE DOM.
IT WAS NEEDLESS TO SAY PROOF
THAT SANDERS WAS A HARDENED
BIGOT, A RACIST.
FOUR YEARS LATER, SANDERS
HAS BECOME OBEDIENT.
NEW PLATFORM CONTAINS ALL
THE OPEN BORDERS RHETORIC.
ENDING DEPORTATIONS,
ABOLISHING ICE.
GIVING BLANKET AMNESTY TO
ALL ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THE
COUNTRY.
RECENTLY ASKED SANDERS WHY
HIS VIEWS CHANGED SO
RADICALLY.
THE MAN WHO ONCE CALLED
IMMIGRATIONEN FORCEMENT A
KOCH BROTHERS CONSPIRACY.
SOUNDED VERY MUCH LIKE A
COKE BROTHER HIMSELF.
>> WE HAVE 11 MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED, MANY OF THOSE
WORKERS, BY THE WAY, ARE
BEING EXPLOITED RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW, TRUMP WANTS TO
THROW EVERYBODY OUT OF THE
COUNTRY.
IF HE THREW PEOPLE OUT OF
THE COUNTRY, THE PRICE OF
FOOD IN THIS COUNTRY WOULD
SKYROCKET.
WHO DO YOU THINK IS PICKING
THE CROPS AND PLANTING ALL
OVER THIS COUNTRY?
>> Tucker: WHO IS PICKING
THE CROPS?
ACTUALLY MACHINES ARE
PICKING MOST OF THE CROPS IN
THIS COUNTRY NOW AND
PLANTING THEM, TOO.
BERNIE IS ALMOST 80 YEARS
OLD AND APPARENTLY NOBODY
TOLD HIM THAT.
EITHER WAY, IT STILL
SHOCKING TO HEAR THAT
EXPLANATION FROM A
SELF-DESCRIBED SOCIALIST.
SO, YES, WORKERS ARE BEING
EXPLOITED BUT THINK ABOUT
WHAT AVOCADOS WOULD COST IF
CITIZENS HAD TO PICK THEM.
IT’S NAUSEATING.
SANDERS ISN’T STUPID.
HE HAS TO KNOW HIS PARTY
IMMIGRATION HURTS WORKERS IN
THE COUNTRY.
HE DESPERATELY WANTS TO BE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
SO HE GOES ALONG WITH IT.
YOU ARE SEEING QUITE A BIT
OF THIS BY THE WAY.
JOE BIDEN, WHO SUPPOSEDLY IS
THE MOST MODERATE MAN IN
POLITICS OLD UNCLE JOE, NOW
IS PUSHING FOR ILLEGAL
ALIENS TO GET OFF ON DUIs.
WATCH.
>>
>> YOU ONLY ARREST FOR THE
PURPOSE OF DEALING WITH A
FELONY THAT’S COMMITTED AND
I DON’T COUNT DRUNK DRIVING
AS A FELONY.
>> Tucker: THE CONFUSED
RAVINGS OF A FADING OLD MAN,
NO, HARDLY.
THEY ALL THINK THAT WAY
RIGHT NOW.
IF DEMOCRATS WIN THE 2020
ELECTION, SOME VERSION OF
THE NEW WAY FORWARD ACT WILL
LIKELY BECOME LAW.
ONCE AGAIN, KEEP THIS IN
MIND, THINGS MOVE FAST IN